one issue that republicans don't want to
touch is the transgender issue
uh it's too touchy it's too complicated
i can't get into it
well a few people have some cajones
including doug lamalfa who is a
congressman from california
who just put out the protecting children
from experimentation act
don't trans the kids you could call it
this would prohibit doctors
from performing the experimental gender
reassignment treatments on children
obviously you can't reassign your gender
but you can castrate children and pump
them full of hormones and
and completely ruin their biology you
can do that and that's probably not a
good thing to do to children
puberty blocking hormones followed by
cross-sex hormones that cause
irreversible damage
to children's bodies including
permanent sterilization including an
increased risk of cancer
including all sorts of terrible things
this congressman came out there
and said no we can't do that anymore the
way republicans are going to win
is not by following the squishy
method of ignoring all the issues that
actually matter and just trying to give
people tax cuts
tax cuts are good too but it has to be
in addition to
taking on head-on these tough cultural
issues
the reason republicans don't want to
take on these tough cultural issues is
because democrats get
violent and they encourage violence and
they they get
vicious when you do that sort of thing
look at what's happening in wisconsin
now all because of the election
that's not a reason to pull back in fact
that's evidence
that when we talk about these cultural
issues we're right over the target we're
doing
exactly what we should be doing because
democrats aren't threatened by low taxes
they can always just raise the taxes
again
what they're threatened by is changing
the cultural perceptions in the country
or by giving voice to the cultural
positions that already exist
and by veering off the course of
progress with a capital p
that involves massive racial division
taking away our cherished legal
and political tradition toppling george
washington
and pumping children full of hormones
that will
castrate them that's progress if that's
progress
i'm not interested in progress i want
whatever the opposite of progress is
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts